freunde herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video ich habe heute etwas
besonderes vor und zwar möchte ich meine
freundin mit den besten teams der welt
überraschend das sind offen pommes einen
ofen macht aber ich nenne sie trotzdem
die besten pommes wir wenn wir nicht die
besten ofen kommen ist der welt weil sie
unglaublich gut sind falls ihr euch
fragt sich ob dieses rezept bekommen bin
ich ja viele youtube videos geschaut ich
selbst beziehe meine rezepte aus youtube
videos vor allem von amerikanischen
youtuber und da hab ich videos geschaut
von candy lautes poltern mit lucia viele
komplizierte namen auf jeden fall hat
jeder die eine oder andere praxis zu
diesem rezept hinzugefügt und es wird
unglaublich lecker ich habe schon mal in
einer frühen form einer kleinen
schwester in einer folge ein tag
persönlicher koch aber wir legen jetzt
erstmal los in den vier kartoffeln
schälen wie ihr euch vielleicht denkt
und können sind kartoffeln nicht ganz
unwichtig für pommes und ich habe die
fläche gekauft die sind fest kochen und
extra finde ich persönlich super leist
das geht auch alles mit kleineren
kartoffeln mit anderen kartoffeln aber
für mich sind das hier die favoriten
weil die pommes halt schön groß werden
also dann wir stehen die kartoffel kommt
rein
zu den besten paul sowie anfangen mit
dem ganzen spaß könnt ihr schon mal
direkt euren backofen auf 230 grad an
machen ober unterhitze und auf eurem
herd ein topf mit wasser aufsetzen das
wasser bringen wir zum kochen also das
ist der teufel die sind super groß
ungefähr ein kilo will ich jetzt mal
schätze und wir schneiden daraus jetzt
eineinhalb zentimeter dicke scheiben
wichtig bei der prozent ist dass man die
kartoffeln vor kopf das sorgt nämlich
später dafür dass die kartoffel außen
knusprig und innen weich werden
das glaube ich da werde ich mir eine
zustimmung für die besten karten in der
welt auf jeden fall gegeben sein muss
also das hier ist eine gute dicke es
muss alles nicht perfekt und symmetrisch
und sonst was soll dadurch kriegt das
ganze diesen homemade style also schauen
unser heutiger gast du hast das wirkt
die besten pommes gegessen
wenn man nicht wirklich gemacht das
stimmt aber ich bin auch anspruchsvoll
was kommt es an gästen dann bist du ja
die perfekte testerin aber der länge
schneiden wir so circa eineinhalb
zentimeter eines ändert zentimeter dicke
streifen und dann haben wir unsere
perfekte größe so also unsere kartoffel
sind geschält und ich finde wirklich das
ist so ein moment also darf hier nicht
so einfach nur cool dass ich irgendwie
so ein bisschen das kochen für mich
entdeckt bei kommen ist das klingt jetzt
vielleicht bescheuert waren für mich
immer so ding was du magischerweise von
bei mcdonald's irgendwie in dieser
packung auftaucht so checkt ihr und ich
finds geil so was selbst zu machen die
besten zutaten zu nehmen und das ganze
noch im level höher zu geben also macht
es auf jeden fall nach super einfach und
ich verspreche euch würde richtig lecker
ist erstmal alles vorbereitet das wasser
kocht jetzt auch jeden moment wäre jetzt
eine schande wenn dieser backofen
plötzlich anfangen würde zu brennen
ich weiß es die täuschend echt aus aber
das ist gerade nur ein special effect
keine sorge ihr könnt mich wieder
beruhigen aber wenn es so wäre dass man
einen backofen anfangen zu brennen
dann werde ottla problem wenn ich nutze
klar und weil sie kleinigkeit klage ist
ein digitaler versicherungsmanager der
für euch alle versicherungen im blick
welt gesagt weil ich weiss wirklich nur
braucht welche auf den kopf so dann
kriegt ihr vielleicht eine offene
brandschutzversicherung ich glaube nicht
dass die gibt der absolute vorteil ist
man kann schon mal den überblick
verlieren ich habe zum beispiel zum
neuen büro da brauchen eine inventar
versicherung damit halt irgendwas
geklaut werden sollte man das geld
wieder bekommen und das kann schon mal
verwirrend sein und den werken tag ins
spiel denn platt gibt ihr eine übersicht
über alle versicherungen die du hast und
die du brauchst also ich fragte das
ganze funktioniert klagt vergleich über
160 verschiedene anbieter von
versicherungen wodurch du auch sparen
kann ist in dem du halt eine
versicherungsleistung optimiert und das
streicht was du nicht brauchst du hast
nicht mehr unmenge von papieren fliegen
weil alles auf der klage auf deinem
smartphone stattfindet und die jetzt ist
natürlich kostenlos für euch zu nutzen
ist euch im app store runterladen die
funktioniert auch in österreich falls
das ganze für euch interessant ist und
wenn ihr noch einen download code max 45
eingekriegt ihren top noch 145 euro also
leute wenn ihr euch nicht so gut mit
versicherung auskennt oder euch das
ganze viel zeit raubt dann checkt auf
jeden fall klage ab das ist super
entspannt und ihr könnt euch wie gesagt
in 45 euro gutscheins eben mit dem code
max 45 wir so ein tolles und das war's
als erstes sei es mir das wasser mit
einer guten prise salz das ist wichtig
damit die pommes auch von innen gesalzen
werden und nicht nur später außen an der
kruste wir geben unsere pornos hinein
und jetzt brauchen wir sie vor wir sind
aber noch nicht ganz fertig weil es
kommen noch eine wichtige zutaten mit in
den tod
und zwar leute geben wir jetzt ein wenig
essig mit in das wasser
das sorgt dafür dass die formel später
ein bisschen elastischer werden und dass
sie somit bei der weiterverarbeitung
nicht zerbrechen
wir gehen hier auch nach gefühlten guten
schluck rein ich habe mich dafür
apfelessig entschieden weil ich habe von
anfang an mit apfelessig gearbeitet hat
das gefühl das gibt dem ganzen sogar
noch so heißen runden geschmack bringen
wir das ganze einmal um das ganze
funktioniert übrigens in dem der esse
ich den stärke abbau verlangsamt und so
behalten die mir ihre stabilität und
werde nicht super weil das habe ich noch
gar nicht gesagt wir kommen die
kartoffeln übrigens acht minuten lang
vor
dann ist es auch schon soweit wundert
euch nicht ich mache haben meine klappe
maschine komplett sauber wir können die
kartoffeln abschütten jetzt lassen wir
so für 23 minuten den wasserdampf von
den promis weg ziehen wir wollen sie
nämlich im ofen so trocken wie möglich
haben damit die oberfläche so knusprig
ihm möglich wird kommen wir zunächst
geheim gefüttert und zwar erdnuss ist
nie so super geheime zum beispiel falsch
benutzt ausschließlich erdnussöl zum
kochen und das hatten bestimmten sinn
erdöl hat einen extrem hohen anteil an
gesättigten fettsäuren und für so thomas
bedeutet das dass sie schneller knusprig
werden bis kein spaß funktioniert
wirklich die pommes sind dann kürzer im
ofen bei
plötzlich werden und sie verlieren
weniger von dieser kleinigkeiten 73
gramm von unserem
ich weiß ist nicht ganz wenig aber es
sind auch prompt ich habe nie gesagt was
ist gesund wird jetzt schnappen wir uns
eine schüssel ist immer noch ein
bisschen am dampfen aber der meister
dann ist jetzt auf jeden fall schon weg
geben wir unsere com ist hier hinein
vorsichtig auch wenn es natürlich durch
den essig ein bisschen geschont haben
aber man sieht schon perfekt zusammen
wenn man das ohne ethik macht zerfallen
und da gehen wir auch schon unsere
erdnussöl drüber dateien das hier ganz
gleichmäßig ich finde wirklich jetzt so
diese mischung aus es ja nicht von
ungefähr
also da gehe jetzt vorsichtig mit den
händen dran und werfen das ganze ein
bisschen durch das alles gleichmäßig mit
öl benetzt ist bücher mir eine mächtige
größe von den promis das steak aus teil
und diese größe ermöglicht dass die
oberfläche knusprig ist und innen drin
alles schön weich bleibt wird meine
hände sind voller höhe der backofen ist
vorgeheizt und hier sehen könnt habe ich
das backblech mit vorgeheizt extrem
wichtig dadurch wird nämlich alles
direkt knusprig braun
also da ich gehe noch einmal durch
funktioniert bestens also alles ist
wirklich zusammen geblieben
jetzt machen wir unseren banken auch und
jetzt gibt es schon jetzt vorsichtig die
pommes braucht ist hier wirklich eine
mac fröhlich spiel aber das ist auch
berechtigt und wir bereiten jetzt alle
pommes ein bisschen aus dateien noch mal
ein bisschen so dass auch wirklich
überall gleich viel
der abstand haben voneinander jäger das
backblech ist desto knuspriger wehrli
commons sowie machen zu ach ja und wir
backen die pommes erstmal für 15 minuten
ich öffne jetzt und wir sehen hier
unsere promis haben ja auf der
außenseite schon eine schöne große
bekommen und auf der unterseite sind sie
schon super christi
wir werden jetzt alle kommen im heißen
fett wie beim ersten mal achten wir
darauf dass sie gleichmäßig verteilt
sind und dann schließen wir wieder für
weitere 15 minuten sofort jetzt ist es
soweit wir machen den ofen auskommen es
haben genau die farbe wie die es gern
hat und jetzt schnappen wir uns das
wirklich mit den kommissionen schütten
das übrig geblieben mit öl ab jetzt
nehmen wir die kosten geht hier in
diesen die schüssel hinein die ich mit
zebra ausgelegt habe kommt mir das ganze
ein bisschen ab hier war nämlich zu viel
fett wie es geht wieder los werden so
bleiben die kommen nämlich schön
knusprig pommes kann man ja mit
verschiedensten sachen würzen aber auf
jeden fall muss immer eine gute prise
salz dabei seien mehr selbst am besten
und schmeißen ist die commons mittelmeer
seite ein bisschen hin und her zu
verlieren
das übrige feld und jetzt kann man nach
geschmack weitere gewürze hinzufügen ich
bereite jetzt zwei verschiedene
portionen vor als erstes machen wir hier
mal eine klassische plain portion aber
nur mit unseren schönen selfmade hohen
preis und die andere variante wird chili
cheese
[Musik]
ok kommen wir zum text heißt ich habe
die kommission mit ein bisschen pfeffer
cayenne normale paprikapulver und
knoblauch pulver gewürzt deine erste
gomez ich muss immer halt du musst mal
wird dazu am besten gefällt mir sogar
dieses kartoffelpüree an der mitte
meckenheim sie sehen und was sagt für
mich wirklich die besten homepage
dies gibt und sie sehen aber auch so
richtig so selfmade ausnehmen
dann lasst uns die regel die zweite
variante probieren mit cherry cheers
also geschmolzener american schießt mit
shader und karla penny war normal eine
ecke um gesunde leute hast du mich
ausgewählt hat dieses video
ich schwöre ich hatte die beste zeit
dafür nicht halt immer geil das was ihr
hier seht war vor eine dreiviertel
stunde noch eine kartoffel kenne ich
liebe es bleibt also leute macht es zu
hause wie mich gibt es dieses und alle
weiteren dezember die ich jemals gemacht
habe für euch wie und wo werdet ihr noch
ein bisschen rätseln müssen aber es wird
auf dem fall sehr wertvoll macht bis
nach